radio chatter Home Secretary Nick Thomas
Simmons joins us now from South Wales
thank you for being on the program today
we've just been listening to Grant
Shapps of course there's legitimate
questions about whether the government's
too slow locking down too slow ramping
up testing getting protective equipment
to the frontline but at the same time
this is the week where they've hit their
target to get a hundred thousand tests
we heard Grant Shapps they're laying out
this idea of a new app and a new contact
tracing system that could be a way out
of lockdown would you give any credit to
the progress that the government's made
recently well we've been asking for the
ramping of the testing for some weeks so
clearly out and please the testing has
been ramped up I think there's always
been a difference between the number of
tests actually carried out and the
overall statistics and indeed the number
of people test it is different figure
but of course I'm pleased that testing
has been ramped up but that in itself is
not a strategy firstly the testing has
to be increased further I mean the
original target we were talking about a
quarter of million air tests a day some
time ago but it has to be linked as you
indicated in your questions Sophie to
tracing as well it's that testing and
tracing that is going to be so important
now in terms of easing the measures of
the lockdown in the weeks and months
ahead okay well you're talking there
about the potential for the lockdown and
in a route out of the the situation
we're in a minute that's going to come
up for review next week do you think
that the measure should be eased
well we won't support as always what the
best public health advice actually says
and I do welcome the fact that last week
the prime minister has indicated that he
has listened to what we've been saying
about publishing an exit strategy and
that is going to be extremely important
it's going to be important both to be
open with the public who've made so many
sacrifices in recent weeks as to what
the future now might hold but also for
our frontline public services so that
they can plan for the various scenarios
that scenarios are going to come in the
next few weeks you see calling for the
government to publish a plan in some
ways that was the easy bit the difficult
bit is working out what should be in
that plan so my question to you is is
there not time for labor to stick its
neck out and actually say what it is
that you would like to see I mean this
is your chance to influence what could
be the biggest decision that the
government makes or this government will
ever make so what measures do you think
it should be looked at well firstly
we've been arguing about the reopening
of schools for some weeks because every
child having access to education is so
important we've also been arguing about
looking at the different sectors of our
economy which which could see
restrictions more likely to be lifted
than others and of course the testing
and tracing strategy that I've already
mentioned and I know that Kirsten will
be speaking to the prime minister early
this week the Welsh Government has sent
over its ideas on an exit strategy and a
formal document as well but what
wouldn't be appropriate Sophie I think
is to set up some sort of rival plan we
will work with the government we want to
do this by agreement we want to support
the exit strategy we went into lockdown
with the political consensus with that
shared objective of minimizing loss of
life I think it's important to try to
come out of lockdown with the consensus
- so just to be clear the first thing
you mentioned there were schools
what does labour think should happen
with schools well we're not asking the
government for the impossible we're not
asking for at the moment a precise date
what we are simply asking for is a road
map as to how we can get our education
system back up but do you think that
road very much should be I mean you can
see other countries doing things
differently Germany prioritizing older
children about to sit exams you can see
France prioritizing nurseries and
primary schools what do you feel the
road batter should be well as I say
start setting out specific details in
that no one can say that they want to
see a road map when it comes to schools
I mean the difficult thing is coming up
with ideas that's no well yes but it is
for the government to come up with the
ideas we will then of course discuss
them and hopefully find
the consents on what they aren't
incidentally I would also say that the
UK government shouldn't be pulling some
sort of rabbit out of a habit they like
don't do work the devolved
administration's that's what I mean work
for the devolved administration's as
well of course hearing why was that
speaking to you it will be a decision
for the Welsh Education Minister but I
would like to see that by consensus we
want to see about the use of technology
we want to see whether it is as you say
Sophie particular age groups that might
come first particular parts of our
education system these are the kind of
things we would want the government to
look at but I'd only it would be helpful
just to simply set of a a rival plan
after having that argument let's move
forward by consensus let's see the
government proposals let's discuss them
next week that see the expert advice and
let's try and move forward by agreement
now and contact tracing of course
there's going to be a big part of our
lockdown exit strategy and you mentioned
it bit earlier in the interview but of
course it requires a certain number of
people to download the app do you think
people should be compelled to download
the app if they can't should there be
fines if you don't for example I think
there has to be a strategy or how we can
ensure there is a very large take-up of
this app app I think it's obvious that
we should need to do that we're willing
to discuss different options for it
however I think there are other matters
we need to take into account here as
well
not everybody has a smartphone in the
first place to which you could download
the app so what is the government's
strategy in relation to that but
secondly as well there are also issues
around privacy and security give you an
example Sophie there are people for whom
location services on their mobile
devices are turned off the particular
safety reasons and keeping themselves
safe oh so we need a strategy and a
parliamentary oversight I would suggest
as well in terms of overall how this is
going to work - now as a shadow home
secretary I'm interested to get your
view on the policing of the lockdown
because it does feel sometimes there's
been a bit of a postcode lottery
policing even individual officers
interpreting things differently at the
Crown Prosecution Service says it's
going to review every charge brought
under the emergency coronavirus laws is
that a good idea and
if you had any concerns about the way
the lockdowns been policed I think the
Crown Prosecution Service are sensible
to do that because we are asking the
police to police something that was
completely new and probably was
unthinkable even four or five months ago
but in general terms I think the police
have done an excellent job and I'm not
saying that they haven't been particular
incidents to which you have alluded in
your question Sophie but we've also got
to be clear that we must back our
frontline police here they've been asked
to do this by us they we passed the
coronavirus act through parliament back
at the end of March with this sweeping
set of powers to the government we then
asked the police to go out and enforce
the lockdown I think by and large
they've done an excellent job and I
think we really need to be thanking and
backing our frontline officers for all
they've done in very very difficult
circumstances now and it's always hard
at interviews to talk about anything
other than coronavirus it feels and but
I am keen to touch on just a couple of
other points now we have you on the
program a new opposition and you Shadow
Cabinet team and I wanted to ask you
about immigration as shadow home
secretary do you feel that free movement
of people should continue after we leave
the European Union well I think what we
will be doing over the next few months
and years coming into setting out our
immigration policy at the next general
election is listening to the concerns of
people but whilst of course we'll set up
that detail in due course I can set out
some broad principles I think firstly
rights about living working studying in
other countries are very important
they're part of the internationalism
that's in Labour's DNA
I think fairness is also going to be so
so important we will never treat people
as statistics in our immigration system
we will always treat them as people and
of course justice is important as well
it's not some abstract principle we've
seen in the windrow scandal what happens
when we lose sight of that in our
immigration system so they are the broad
principles that we'll be drawing on as
we move forward to set out our position
in more detail in the years ahead
so those the broad principles but I am
interested in specifics as well I mean
que estar mo in the leadership contest
said that he thought labour should argue
in favor of free movement of people so
do you think three million people should
continue we will always make the
positive case or immigration and the
great benefits that immigration has
brought to our country but clearly it's
not quite what I asked but firstly we
will be elite would have left the
European we have left the European Union
and the transition people have ended by
the time we get to the next general
election it will be this government
there will have negotiated that new
agreement with the European Union we're
also going through the coronavirus
crisis where vast parts of the world are
in lockdown you can't even travel from
one part of the world to another so we
will of course be shaping our
immigration policy around those events
and those changes and by the way I would
also say that what we've seen in the
coronavirus crisis is the value of
people refuse collectors are shop
workers are nurses are local government
workers all of whom are doing a
wonderful job keeping our country
running where their salary doesn't
reflect their value and the government
is trying to convince us that anyone who
name less than twenty five thousand six
hundred fans a year is unskilled some of
us didn't need reminding that that
wasn't the case but if anyone did need
reminding I think we've seen in the
coronavirus crisis the value of people
who are on salaries that are lower than
that and that doesn't reflect what they
do and just finally as well the other
thing we've seen of course in the
coronavirus crisis is that those from
VME backgrounds appear to be more at
risk or serious complications now public
health England has given Trevor Phillips
a role in to the inquiry into why that
might be
now some campaigners have protested that
he shouldn't be a part of that inquiry
because the past comments he's made
about Muslims others say that this is a
man who spent his life campaigning for
racial inequality it's his friends in
the labour party who should be sticking
up for him kids Thomas says that the
government should engage with the
concerns of the campaigners is that the
right decision or should co-star might
be supporting Trevor Phillips Nokia star
is quite right
say that we should be engaging with
those concerns I think that's entirely
the right approach given the issues that
have been raised but I should also say
that we as a Labour Party have asked
Doreen Lorenz who's got obviously you
know it was great campaigning history in
this area after such a tragic event with
the murder of course of Stephen Lawrence
she will be looking at it for us and
this thing control issue going forward
looking at the impact of the corona
virus and it's disparate impact it seems
on baam unities which is something we do
need to learn the lessons of going
forward okay Nick Thomas Simmons thank
you very much for being on the program
and talking about variety things thank
you thank you